hey lebron who you've prided yourself on
being able to play whatever position is
needed to play whatever needs to be done
in the court just wondered over the last
couple of years what you've observed
about
roster and going into next season you
know how this year contrasted with the
previous two and if you started to have
those kind of thoughts yet i mean it's
human nature to automatically start
thinking about
the roster and what it could look like
and and how we can
obviously
have a roster that
brings in more wins i mean that's the
that's the most important thing that's
the job that we in so
um i've started to think about it a
little bit but you know
it's not
you know sorely on me obviously um but
we definitely want to be better we want
to be better coming in next year that's
the most important thing for the summer
and just to follow up position wise you
know you played some more center this
year you played point guard like is just
for you is there a is there an optimal
there is it is it being able to go back
and forth to different positions
depending on who's on the roster uh it
doesn't matter for me personally you
know my uh
you know my personal um goal is to be
able to play any position on the floor
you know and every game is different
you know matchups is different at times
so to be able to have the availability
to our team that i could
switch off and play center for minutes
or play point guard for minutes or
play the wing spot
for minutes according to what the game
dictates her needs
you know that's for me to uh
to make sure that i'm equipped um i'm in
the best possible shape i can be in
to help us win ballgames
you see yourself being with this
franchise and you're here and this
summer you're gonna be up uh eligible
for a contract extension um
do you intend to
extend with the lakers this summer and
what what are the determining factors
that will go into that decision-making
process uh well the conversation uh
hasn't been
talked about or technically because of
collective bargaining agreement cannot
even be discussed
um until later on in the year so
you know i know it's out there but we
can't even myself and rich can't even
begin to talk with rob or the front
office at all because of
uh the collective bargaining agreement
so when we get to that point
uh we'll see